welcome to this evening's performance of
film theory before we begin tonight's
presentation we kindly ask that you take
the time now to unwrap any candies you
may have because that's a thing that
apparently annoys some people tonight's
performance will
include a short intermission provided
brands care enough about this channel to
spend money on a mid-roll ad
now please turn off your cell phones and
wait most of you are probably watching
on cell phones don't do that don't turn
off your cell phones keep your cell
phones loud and active
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
where today it's probably more accurate
to call the show film theatrical
presentation sent to direct digital
release theory since we're talking about
the broadway musical turned disney cash
cow
hamilton when it comes to talking about
broadway musicals well usually it'd be
outside the realm of my channels which
is a shame since as many of you know i
was in a past life
a touring actor and director
[Applause]
but since a filmed version of hamilton
just came out to near universal praise
on disney plus
looks like i finally have an excuse to
talk about it and let's just say
i am not throwing away my shots oh and
uh if you're already tired of these puns
from the show
got some bad news because never gonna be
satisfied
oh and uh for those of you who haven't
seen the musical or the disney plus
version yet this will be a mostly
spoiler-free theory don't worry i won't
go ruining anything big like telling you
who wins the american revolutionary war
you'll just have to watch it for
yourself and find out what happens to
that young scrappy and hungry country
but rather than talking about how
dangerous it was to shoot a flintlock
pistol straight into the air or go
through the bizarre economics that
explains why king george iii
was probably right i'm doing something a
little bit different today
i'm gonna try to get hamilton qualified
for the academy awards maybe not so far
as a nomination
and certainly not a win although that
would be great today we're starting
smaller we're just trying to get
hamilton
it's shot at taking home its very own
oscar but to truly understand what i'm
talking about why it matters and how
today we might be able to
single-handedly change the entire face
of cinema as we know it that's barely an
exaggeration by the way
we first have to rewind rewind
rewind rewind we rhyme for those of you
who don't know hamilton
a musical about the life of founding
father to the us alexander hamilton
started its broadway run back in 2015.
the next year the original cast recorded
two live performances and then a third
performance
specifically for cameras the rights to
distribute the resulting movie went up
for sale and were snagged by disney who
decided to lock hamilton in the good old
disney vault until 2021 but
after everyone got themselves locked
inside this year disney decided that
well they had this complete movie anyway
may as well release it to get everyone
hooked on disney plus and it is
great i mean it was a fantastic stage
show to begin with and they filmed it so
you know it's a great recording of what
is a phenomenal live stage production
anyway this has prompted many hamel fans
to ask the question could this filmed
production of hamilton actually be
nominated for
and heck even win an oscar because let's
be honest the field this year is looking
pretty thin with many films being
indefinitely delayed in order to get to
10 films in the current 2020 best
picture lineup you're looking at
something like
sonic the hedgehog bad boys for life
trolls world tour
onward birds of prey call of the wild do
little scoob artemis fowl and
impractical
jokers the movie i mean hamilton has to
edge out at least
one of those right now in a normal year
the fact that hamilton started on a
streaming service would actually
disqualify
you for the oscar their rules state that
a film needs to have debuted in los
angeles county theaters before or
on the same day as being streamed more
specifically from the rule set quote a
film must have a minimum seven day
theatrical run in a los angeles county
commercial theater with at least three
screenings per day
for paid admission now that might seem
really dumb and super arbitrary but if
you think about it it does kind of make
sense the academy of motion picture arts
and sciences the one that gives away the
academy awards is built on the idea of
preserving the art of movies and the
importance of seeing them on a big
screen so making sure that a film runs
in a theater is a big deal for their
brand
this year however things are different
and due to almost all the feeders being
closed down the academy has actually
decided to allow
streaming debuts to qualify huzzah
hooray
all you fans that were worried about the
billion dollar 11 time tony award
winning musical can rest easy now
knowing that it'll get even more money
and even more accolades
or can you actually rest easy no you
can't hamilton
is still disqualified according to an
article by vanity fair on july 6 a
representative from the academy said
that hamilton is still not qualified
because of a rule stating quote
works that are essentially promotional
or instructional
are not eligible nor are works that are
essentially unfiltered records
of performances so bummer theory over
right
nope because i think the academy's wrong
i think they're interpreting their own
rules incorrectly and moreover i think
they're interpreting what a movie
is incorrectly and today i'm going to
prove all of it because in a year we're
at slim pickens for the academy
i think it might be nice it might be
nice
to have hamilton fans on their side
first let's look at those oscar rules
shall we while yes it is true that there
is a rule specifically banning
unfiltered records of performances
this rule is specifically for the
documentary category which is decidedly
not hamilton i know this may come as a
surprise academy of motion picture arts
and sciences but hamilton is shockingly
not a documentary about the founding of
america i was surprised too but then i
looked around and realized oh wait there
are no slaves here but all joking aside
even if this was
a wider sweeping rule hamilton on disney
plus is certainly
not an unfiltered record in fact it is
neither
unfiltered nor a record as i mentioned
already the filmed version of hamilton
was shot over the course of three
different shows two of those shows were
in front of an audience but the third
show was done
entirely for the camera so they could
get those juicy close-ups
those three recordings were then cut
together to produce an entirely new work
what we now know as hamilton the movie
on disney plus
it's not the record of any one
standalone event that ever happened
instead it's a series of takes all
edited together to tell a cohesive
narrative
just like you do with any other movie in
existence
they even ended up with continuity
errors as the result of this multi-day
shoot in the song satisfied
flowers on angelica's blouse appear and
disappear throughout the performance
no flowers flowers no flowers flowers if
this truly is unfiltered then i need to
know exactly what substance those
flowers are made of so i can make an
invisibility cloak and finally steal the
diet coke secret formula
in short hamilton on disney plus uses
the two things that separate movies from
stage shows
cinematography and editing you see on
stage you can always try to direct your
audience's eyes to the things that you
want them to see
via techniques like lighting and
blocking aka the position and movement
of the people and things on stage but
you're not guaranteed to that maybe the
audience is just really interested in
the elaborate backstory that chorus
dancer number three has concocted for
himself back there and chooses to watch
him instead
additionally at no point can i as the
director of the show present that
audience member with a different view of
the events happening on stage
they're either getting the 600 view from
orchestra center or the student discount
view where half the stage is obstructed
from side balcony a
but with film cinematography allows you
as the director to manage
all of that stuff i can choose to focus
the camera on specific characters or
actions and ignore others i can move the
camera to create angles that you would
never be able to accomplish on stage and
hamilton on disney plus
does exactly that thanks to the magic of
cinema we get some amazing shots like
this one of angelica's face immediately
after she introduces alexander to her
sister giving up her own chance with him
during the story of tonight the camera
makes sure to stay
centered around the four characters of
the gang by keeping the framing tight it
helps the cinematic audience forget the
huge empty stage around the actors which
makes their ideological cries for
freedom seem much more important in
all-encompassing rather than ringing out
to an empty hall
later while thomas jefferson is gloating
that hamilton's never gonna be president
we're treated to a top-down shot now i
know seating for hamilton's limited but
i didn't realize they were putting the
audience in the rafters
they even use the camera cuts to enhance
punch lines like the moment king george
iii finds out who's taken over for
george washington
john adams each one is an intentional
camera placement or movement that uses
the medium of
film to change the way that the viewer
perceives these scenes
relative to the way that they would
experience them as the audience in a
live theater show but the other half of
this equation is editing in a live show
you can't go back and erase a flood line
or
choose to redo an emotional beat to make
it stronger but in a film
you can editing choosing what takes to
keep and how to best splice them
together that helps tell the story just
as much as the actors do when it comes
to the art of cinema and in the filmed
recordings of hamilton again
they choose to do exactly this in the
song satisfied it's taken to an extreme
with
rapid cuts from varied angles that keep
the viewing audience as off-kilter as
the character on stage who's trying to
figure out how she feels about
everything going on around her
in the song non-stop it's a bit more the
opposite longer shots with the camera
swinging around in wide arcs pulling
ever more characters and action into
frame as hamilton's head spins and of
course you can't ignore the editing
decision to leave
every juicy king george appearance in
extreme close-up
foo the first row needs to come with a
splash guard warning so at this point i
think it's pretty clear that hamilton
falls squarely within the rules of a
movie that should be qualified for oscar
consideration
not a guaranteed nomination or anything
but at least worth being considered
for one but let's stop talking about
hamilton specifically and ask the wider
question why is filmed theater being
disqualified
in the first place i mean it used to be
valid back in 1966 sir lawrence olivier
scored a best actor nomination for his
performance of othello in a filmed stage
production then again
in 1976 the film give em hell harry
which was a live theatrical recording of
a one-man stage play was nominated for
best actor
so why would filming something live on a
theatrical stage in one long take
inherently disqualify it as an artistic
work i mean think about it honestly in
the past few years the oscar for best
cinematography has gone to both 1917
and birdman two movies that have
expressly used longer takes and
disguised their edits
in order to make it seem like one long
continuous shot
and then what about the acting for those
sorts of movies shooting those sorts of
extended takes requires the actors to be
in character longer hitting their marks
and being emotionally invested in the
scene for longer periods of time quite
literally
the exact same things that theatrical
actors are required to do on stage
each and every night ironically enough
films have been pushing towards
and getting rewarded by the academy four
pushing towards more of a live theater
aesthetic for the better part of the
last decade so to exclude
live theatrical recordings seems both
narrow-minded and
arbitrary it also brings up the
challenge that you've now set up for
yourself
where do you draw the line how
theatrical is too theatrical
theater and movie making both require
large teams with sets
blocking hitting marks memorizing lines
lighting sound
in filmmaking sometimes you take the
300th take but sometimes you take the
first take is getting it in one take any
different from getting one shot at a
theatrical performance do you see
how this quickly becomes a slippery
slope movie industry case in point what
about the very intense and experimental
movie dogville
starring nicole kidman one of your
favorites and directed by the famous
lars von trier it takes place on a black
sound stage with location outlines drawn
and labeled on the ground with props and
set dressing all being pant-mined or
alluded to via sound effects it's a film
certainly but it's using very theatrical
conventions the minimalist style is
actually very reminiscent of the
theatrical work
of famous playwright and director
bertolt brecht who tended to use bare
staging to focus the audience's
attention on the acting and storytelling
by exposing the conventions
of the theater not trying to hide things
like lights and sets his hope was to
make viewers constantly aware
of the theater's artificiality dogville
the movie plays
heavily in this theatrical world and yet
dogville is still very much a movie
winning numerous awards at film
festivals around the world so again i
ask how theatrical is too theatrical
where does the line sit
to me the only only differentiators are
cinematography
and editing by those two tokens you
require nominees to be
anything that's been put on a camera and
displayed on a screen and why not
why would you want to limit it to much
more than that if you open the door to
hamilton
so what what's the risk that hollywood
suddenly gets shown up by broadway good
people in theater deserve more respect
many of them are more talented actors
and directors than some of the biggest
names out there
yeah i said it uh sorry i've wanted to
rant about that for years but this was
my only chance to do it i just think
that theater actors get totally trampled
on
anyway i ask again what's the risk of
opening the door to filmed productions
of live theatrical performances are
theatrical shows gonna be at a
disadvantage
yeah i just talked about the continuity
errors on angelica's blouse so you know
hamilton probably won't be winning any
editing awards this year
and from a cinematography angle yeah
they're using some fun shots but it's
still
pretty basic could it win for acting
though sure why not
it contains some of the best acting that
i've seen on a screen
all year and shouldn't that be enough
theater and filmmaking are cut from the
same cloth they're variations of an art
form and in a year where the slate of
potential oscar nominees ain't looking
too great i'd much rather see leslie
odom jr or renee elise goldsberry
get rewarded for their incredible work
that they did on film than have to give
the win to a blue
cgi hedgehog doing the floss but hey
that's just a theory a film
theory and scene